Diese Entdeckung ist wirklich mehr als spektakulär:
Ein Forschungsteam hat jetzt das älteste
intakte Schiffswrack überhaupt entdeckt.
Es liegt im Schwarzen Meer in einer Tiefe
von 2.000 Metern und ist sage und schreibe
vor 2.400 Jahren gesunken.
Diesen Typ Handelsschiff kannte man bisher
nur von antiken Abbildungen.
Das Krasse daran: Es ist so gut erhalten als
wäre es gestern erst gesunken.
Denn in der “Todeszone” des Schwarzen
Meeres blieb es wie in einer Art Zeitkapsel
erhalten.
Welche Geheimnisse das Wrack lüften kann
- das alles und noch viel mehr erfahrt ihr
jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier
gibt es täglich spannende Science Videos
herzlich willkommen!
Eigentlich war das britische Unterwasser-Archäologen-Team
im Schwarzen Meer vor der bulgarischen Küste
unterwegs, um den Meeresgrund in der Region
zu kartieren.
Vor allem die Veränderungen des Schwarzen
Meeres seit der letzten Eiszeit sollten untersucht
werden.
Doch am Meeresboden erwartete sie eine riesige
Überraschung: Viele Schiffswracks nämlich,
von denen die meisten äußerst gut erhalten
sind.
Unter anderem auch ein Exemplar, das ein wirklich
spektakuläres Zeugnis der antiken Welt darstellt.
Ein griechisches Handelsschiff - und zwar
vollständig erhalten.
Heißt also: samt Steuer, Rumpf und den Ruderbänken.
Dazu ein beteiligter Wissenschaftler: “Es
sieht wirklich so aus, als sei es gestern
erst gesunken.”
Das Wrack liegt auf der Seite und ist etwa
23 Meter lang.
Mittlerweile hat das Forschungsteam das Holz
des Wracks genauer untersucht.
Laut der Radiokohlenstoffdatierung ist das
Schiff wohl 400 vor Christus gesunken - somit
ist es 2400 Jahre alt und damit das älteste
Schiffswrack weltweit.
Dazu Jon Adams von der University of Southampton:
“Ein Schiff, das unter zwei Kilometer Wasser
aus der antiken Welt intakt überdauert, ist
etwas, das ich zuvor niemals für möglich
gehalten hatte”.
Doch wie ist diese gute Konservierung überhaupt
möglich?
Verantwortlich dafür sind die Bedingungen
im Schwarzen Meer - in der sogenannten “Todeszone”.
Damit sind die unteren Wasserschichten gemeint,
in denen kaum Sauerstoff existiert und damit
auch keinerlei Leben.
Bedingt dadurch, dass das Schwarze Meer eben
nur über den engen Bosporus an wenig sauerstoffreiches,
frisches Wasser kommt.
Hier findet keinerlei Zersetzung statt und
das Schiff “überlebte” zwei Jahrtausende
quasi wie in einer Zeitkapsel.
Was das Schiff geladen hatte, ist bisher allerdings
noch nicht erforscht.
Um die Entdeckung genauer zu untersuchen,
müssten noch Fragen zur Finanzierung des
Projektes geklärt werden.
Fest steht jedenfalls: Die Entdeckung des
Wracks ist nicht nur deswegen ganz besonders,
weil es so gut erhalten ist, sondern eben
auch, weil man diesen Schiffstyp noch nie
in echt gesehen hatte.
Sondern immer nur auf antiken Abbildungen,
wie etwa der sogenannten “Sirenen-Vase”.
Gemeint ist damit ein Gefäß, das ein Abenteuer
von Odysseus, einem Held der griechischen
Mythologie, zeigt.
Das britische Forschungsteam ist immer noch
überwältigt von dem Fund.
Dazu Adams: “Dieser Fund wird unser Verständnis
des Schiffsbaus und der Seefahrt in der antiken
Welt verändern.
Da liegen Schiffe dort unten, die man noch
nie gesehen hat – abgesehen von Wandfresken
oder Malereien.”
Sein Team hatte schon in den vergangenen Jahren
spannende Funde im Schwarzen Meer gemacht.
Beispielsweise Kriegsflotten der Kosaken aus
dem 17.
Jahrhundert oder auch römische Handelsschiffe,
samt Ladung.
Diese Entdeckungen verdeutlichen, wie wichtig
das Schwarze Meer für die früheren Kulturen
war: Viele Reiche der Antike und des Altertums
grenzten an seine Küsten.
Da können wir also noch die ein oder andere
Überraschung erleben.
Wenn ihr dazu und zu allen anderen Themen
kein Video verpassen wollt, dann abonniert
auch den englischen Kanal von Clixoom.
Denn auch da gibt es die ein oder andere Videopremiere.
Klickt einfach hier drauf und darunter geht
es weiter mit: Myths, Legends and Speculations:
The Eight Most Exciting Pyramid Facts!
Hoffentlich sehen wir uns also auf dem englischen
Kanal.
Stay tuned, see you soon.